-Un petit mot
a une énorme
signification.
-Vous en avez assez
de cette bande de racailles ?
-C'est inadmissible !
-On a de plus en plus
de petites phrases
dans le débat public.
-Le bruit et l'odeur...
-Je ne pense pas
que ce soit volontaire,
le fait qu'il sorte
des petits trucs comme ça.
Quoi que...
-On est les sans-dents
de la République !
-Il y a une majorité
de femmes,
il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup,
illettrées.
-Après le scandale des sans-dents,
voici celui des illettrées !
-C'est violent,
c'est extrêmement violent.
-Attention
à ce nouveau langage.
-François Hollande,
Emmanuel Macron,
deux ambitieux
issus de l'élite
de la nation.
Deux présidents portés
au pouvoir par la gauche
et par l'espoir
d'un renouveau.
-Vive la France !
-Si le protégé
a trahi son mentor,
tous deux ont été pris en défaut
par leurs petites phrases.
Accusés de mépris
envers les plus pauvres.
-Il y a, dans cette société,
une majorité de femmes.
Il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup, illettrées.
-"Illettrées",
"sans-dents", des mots
dits en public ou en privé,
assumés ou non mais qui ont mis
au jour leur décalage
avec le peuple,
jusqu'à provoquer
la colère de la rue.
-On dit
qu'on est les sans-dents
de la République,
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
de nous.
-2014, c'est l'année
de tous les extrêmes.
Le climat s'affole.
-2014, année
la plus chaude
depuis un siècle.
-Les milliardaires,
eux, amassent.
-Les 300 personnalités
les plus riches de la planète
ont gagné en 2013
381 milliards d'euros.
-En 2014,
les Français découvrent
les infidélités du président
et ses escapades en scooter,
à la une de la presse
à scandales.
Un ministre,
Thomas Thévenoud,
découvreur
d'une maladie :
la phobie administrative.
-La République exemplaire,
c'est quoi ?
-Il n'est pas en règle
avec le fisc.
Un petit tour
et puis s'en va.
-En 2014, le Front National
gagne les européennes.
Première victoire du parti
à une élection nationale.
Le PS, divisé comme jamais,
s'effondre aux municipales.
Cliquetis d'appareils photos
Août 2014, après
trois mois seulement,
le gouvernement formé
par Manuel Valls prend l'eau.
-Tout est dans le symbole.
Pour sa fête de la Rose,
Arnaud Montebourg
a choisi une cuvée,
celle du Redressement,
qu'il adresse au président.
-Je vais lui envoyer une bouteille
de la cuvée du Redressement.
-Trois ministres,
parmi les plus à gauche
quittent le navire,
en désaccord
avec la politique économique
de François Hollande.
-C'est le jour...
On est le 25 août 2014,
où il vient à l'île de Sein.
25 août, normalement,
il n'y a pas de tempête.
Sauf qu'il y a une tempête
épouvantable,
et une pluie épouvantable.
-Le message de l'île de Sein,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de péril,
pas de difficulté,
que nous ne puissions surmonter
dès lors que la volonté existe.
-C'est le moment
où ils partent,
Montebourg, Hamon
et Filippetti.
Il perd 3 ministres d'un coup.
-Sale temps pour le président.
Une petite tempête
qui en annonce une grande.
Elle arrive
quelques jours après,
à la surprise générale.
-C'est un livre
de 320 pages,
écrit dans le plus grand secret.
-Une nouvelle étape
dans la confusion
entre vie privée et vie publique.
-Jamais une ex-Première dame
ne s'était confié ainsi.
-C'est une daube,
on peut le dire.
C'est un très mauvais livre.
"Le journal de Mickey" est mieux.
-C'est un livre qui s'est vendu
très, très largement.
Les Français aiment bien
lire des livres
quand ils peuvent regarder
par le trou de la serrure.
C'est un livre
"trou de la serrure".
-Je dois dire que
j'ai un petit peu honte,
un sentiment de voyeurisme,
mais que j'assume.
C'est quelqu'un qui...
Désolée de dire ça,
ça m'embête toujours
de parler
des sentiments des autres,
mais qui se venge,
quand même,
d'une situation personnelle,
en disant :
"Ce président
est inconstant", etc.
-Je l'ai lu en entier.
Il y a
des pages agréables,
mais on voit
qu'à certains moments,
à certaines pages,
il est fait
pour nuire, pour blesser
François Hollande.
-Ce bouquin n'a pas
fait de bien.
Il n'a pas fait de bien.
Il a atteint son objectif.
-"Merci pour ce moment",
un brûlot vendu
à plus de 750 000 exemplaires,
qui décrit
sans pudeur
9 ans de la vie du couple,
jusqu'à leur séparation
en janvier 2014.
300 pages de règlement
de compte privé
dont une petite phrase
va avoir d'énormes
conséquences publiques.
-La seule chose
qui était, pour lui,
la plus grave
dans le livre
était qu'elle l'accusait
de traiter les pauvres
de sans-dents.
C'est ce qui était
le plus lourd pour lui.
-La phrase sur les sans-dents
m'a surprise
car je connais
François Hollande,
j'ai pas été d'accord avec
les options qu'il a prises
en particulier,
à la fin de son mandat,
sur ce que j'appelle
"la tentation néo-libérale".
Mais je connais l'homme,
et son empathie globale
à l'égard des gens,
même si certains disent
qu'il est ni bon,
ni rond, ni généreux,
je crois
qu'il a vraiment envie
que les gens aillent mieux.
Pour faire court.
-Ca ne se fait pas
en public,
c'est dans un contexte
privatif.
C'est une formule
qui est censée
ramasser toute une série
de traits qui caractérisent
celles et ceux
qui sont véritablement
en bas de l'échelle sociale,
et dont la condition sociale
ne se lit pas juste
sur leur bulletin de salaire
mais sur leurs corps.
-L'expression "sans-dents"
a la force des expressions
figuratives.
C'est-à-dire
qu'elle donne à voir.
Elle énonce un thème,
la pauvreté, non pas
avec un concept,
comme la misère, par exemple,
mais à travers une image.
Cette image résonne
profondément
dans la mémoire figurative
des Français.
-Ca envoie un message
de stigmatisation.
Les classes populaires,
surtout celles qui sont
en bas de l'échelle sociale,
ne s'attendent pas
à être qualifiées ainsi.
C'est une image d'elles-mêmes,
qui, lorsqu'elle est une réalité,
qu'ils préfèrent oublier.
C'est les gens d'en haut
qui parlent aux gens d'en bas,
en insistant
sur un attribut qu'ils ont,
toute leur dentition,
et que les gens d'en bas
n'ont hélas plus.
-L'expression prêtée
à François Hollande,
par son ex-compagne,
avait fait la une
de la presse.
Bien évidemment,
en tant que dentiste,
mon attention avait été
aussitôt attirée,
l'expression est
quand même assez dure,
si vous voulez,
et injuste.
C'est injuste
de dire ça.
Si quelqu'un n'a pas de dents,
c'est pas du tout de sa faute,
ou ça peut ne pas
être de sa faute.
C'est une question de manque
de moyens financiers.
-Les sans-dents,
ou comment un moment volé
de la vie privée
de François Hollande
va le toucher
en tant qu'homme,
et anéantir
toute une vie
d'engagement politique.
-François Hollande
est un président
socialiste, de gauche.
Ce qui peut toucher,
en fait, la vie,
l'engagement politique
de François Hollande,
et à travers lui,
les socialistes,
c'est cette expression.
-Un homme de gauche
qui méprise les pauvres,
c'est la contradiction
idéologique maximale.
C'est même ce qui a été dit,
c'est l'expression du cynisme.
-Je n'ai jamais
entendu François Hollande
parler comme ça.
Hollande n'a jamais eu de mépris
à l'égard des gens de la pauvreté.
Jamais. Qui vivent
la pauvreté.
-Face à la déferlante
médiatique,
le président est contraint
de réagir publiquement.
Habituellement
jovial et blagueur,
il a perdu son sourire.
Fait exceptionnel : il le fait
lors d'un sommet international
devant la presse
du monde entier, signe
de la gravité
de la situation.
-Le livre de l'ex-Première dame
a beaucoup de succès.
Ne craignez-vous pas,
au-delà
du plan personnel,
que des révélations
dégradent irrémédiablement
votre crédibilité
et la fonction présidentielle ?
-Je n'accepterai jamais,
je dis bien, jamais,
que puisse être mis en cause
ce qui est l'engagement
de toute ma vie.
Je ne vais pas laisser
mettre en cause
la conception de mon action
au service des Français.
Et notamment de la relation humaine
que j'ai avec les plus fragiles.
Je suis à leur service.
C'est ma raison d'être.
Tout simplement
ma raison d'être.
-On attend le retour
de François Hollande
qui revient de Cardiff.
Il s'adresse à nous
avec la pudeur
de François Hollande.
Il n'aime pas du tout
parler de sa vie privée.
Et il nous dit :
"Je n'ai pas le droit
"de communiquer
mes sentiments.
"Mon devoir,
quoi qu'il m'arrive,
"à moi, est de préserver
la fonction présidentielle."
-Présentez... Armes !
-Je le connais depuis 35 ans.
Il a une sacrée
solidité intérieure.
Il prendra,
comme on dit, tout sur lui.
-Quelques jours après,
François Hollande brise l'armure
dans une interview
au Nouvel Observateur,
blessé...
-Valérie Trierweiler
peut avoir écrit beaucoup de choses
sur leur vie intime,
mais lui prêter à lui l'expression
les "sans dents",
c'est beaucoup trop.
-...et livre sa version
des "sans dents".
-Il essaye de recontextualiser
l'expression
pour lui retirer
cette généralisation
qui serait la définition
des pauvres.
Ca n'est pas une généralisation
de la pauvreté en général.
Autrement dit,
la connotation de l'expression,
dans le contexte
de François Hollande,
c'est une connotation
compassionnelle,
alors que changée de contexte,
ça devient
une connotation méprisante
-Dans le livre,
Valérie Trierweiler, évidemment,
tord un peu les choses
et considère qu'il est méprisant
et qu'il qualifie les pauvres
de "sans dents".
-François Hollande
peine à se défendre.
Si les mots ont été dits en privé,
l'expression dans sa bouche
est crédible.
Lui, auteur de bons mots,
paierait-il cette propension
à l'humour,
dont il est coutumier ?
-Moi, j'ai été
dans le même lycée
que Clavier et Jugnot
donc j'ai gardé, finalement,
une fidélité à ce comique-là.
Je suis "café-théâtre",
si vous voulez.
Je ne peux pas,
comme président de la République,
supprimer la pluie.
Je ne peux pas non plus
la provoquer,
même si certains
ont imaginé
cette hypothèse.
Je leur dis :
"Un euro,
"mais un euro,
ce n'est pas cher
"pour se débarrasser
de Nicolas Sarkozy, payez, payez !"
Vous connaissez la nouvelle ?
Le président candidat
est désormais candidat président.
Acclamations
-Il manie l'humour.
Ah, ça, il est plutôt cinglant.
Il peut même être,
d'ailleurs, cruel,
avec l'humour.
Il peut blesser en l'utilisant.
-On peut aller loin
dans l'humour français.
C'est pour ça qu'on choque
les anglo-saxons
qui pensent que l'humour français
est iconoclaste,
transgressant les frontières.
-C'est un vélo
de la gauche plurielle.
Plusieurs selles,
une direction.
Rires
-Mais pour un homme de gauche,
même si on le fait
au travers de l'humour,
faut pas transgresser
certains tabous.
Il y a d'autres façons
de les qualifier
qu'en utilisant ce terme.
-Il est frappant de constater que,
pendant sa mandature,
François Hollande
a limité considérablement
sa propension aux mots d'esprit
et à l'humour
parce que le propre
d'un mot d'esprit,
c'est d'être ambigu,
et c'est justement
le jeu sur une ambiguïté
qui permet
de jouer sur le contexte.
Et si on change
le contexte,
il peut devenir catastrophique.
C'est le propre de l'ironie.
La fameuse histoire
de Montesquieu
sur les esclaves :
"Si j'avais à défendre les esclaves,
je dirais qu'ils ont un gros nez."
C'est ironique
mais ça a été interprété,
jusqu'au 20e siècle,
comme non ironique
car décontextualisé.
-Le contexte
de cette petite phrase
va connaître
un nouvel éclairage
quelques années plus tard.
En 2016, François Hollande
se confie longuement
à deux journalistes dans un livre
et revient sur l'expression
les "sans dents"
qu'il admet avoir utilisée
en privé
mais sans mépris. Réponse immédiate
de son ex-compagne
sur Twitter
qui persiste et signe.
Valérie Trierweiler publie un SMS,
vieux de 8 ans,
attribué à François Hollande.
-Cette histoire est remarquable,
parce qu'elle change le registre.
C'est-à-dire qu'ici,
ce que l'on voit,
c'est que la "Bernadette",
c'est Bernadette Chirac.
-Les faits remontent
au 31 mai 2008.
Le président du conseil général
de Corrèze, François Hollande,
et la conseillère générale
du canton de Sarran,
Bernadette Chirac, inaugurent
ce jour-là un centre culturel
dans leur département.
-C'est ce registre
de la dérision,
de ce fameux trait d'humour,
caractéristique de la personnalité
du discours de François Hollande,
qui fait qu'on peut se dire,
si on interprète la chose,
que c'est un petit mot
qu'ils ont entre eux,
une sorte
de petite plaisanterie.
Si on est attentif,
le contexte du discours
montre que c'est
un mot d'esprit partagé,
qu'elle-même doit l'utiliser.
-Bonjour, madame.
-En déballant un échange privé,
Valérie Trierweiler se piège
en révélant que l'expression
attribuée à François Hollande
serait partie de Corrèze.
-Les édentés, on va plus les voir
dans les milieux défavorisés,
soyons clairs.
On va plus les voir
au niveau de la France profonde.
Là vous verrez,
en regardant bien les gens,
et surtout quand vous avez
un oeil de dentiste,
vous verrez assez facilement
des gens qui ont des dents en moins,
des dents de devant,
de derrière,
et qui ne se les font pas
remplacer.
Ce sont des gens
qui auraient les moyens
de se les faire remplacer
mais qui n'y attachent pas
une importance folle.
S'il leur manque une dent,
ça ne les gêne pas pour vivre,
dans les contacts sociaux.
-Le président de la République.
-Quoi qu'il en soit,
François Hollande paye,
dès sa révélation,
un lourd prix politique
pour une formule privée
qui n'avait pas vocation
à devenir publique.
-Il arrive
au plus mauvais moment car
ça y est, le président perd la main.
On sent peut-être
que François Hollande
va vers un destin
qui sera celui
du premier président sortant
qui ne peut pas se représenter.
Ca finira comme ça.
-C'est une phrase qui a été redite
par volonté de nuire,
donc mise en scène,
dans le bouquin, et mise en scène
pour atterrir sur des banderoles.
-HOLLANDE, T'ES FOUTU !
LES "SANS DENTS" SONT DANS LA RUE !
HOLLANDE, T'ES FOUTU !
LES "SANS DENTS"
SONT DANS LA RUE !
-Qu'est-ce qu'on dit ?
On descend dans la rue,
on est les "sans dents"
de la République, actuellement.
-HOLLANDE, T'ES FOUTU !
-L'expression était intéressante.
Les manifestants
se sont pas trompés,
ils ont eu exactement
la même analyse
et ils en ont profité,
si je puis dire,
pour l'attaquer, l'accuser
à partir de cette expression.
En l'écrivant,
elle savait ce qu'elle faisait
parce que l'auteur
est aussi journaliste.
-C'est la manière dont un petit mot
a une énorme signification.
Je prends l'image du mot comme
une sorte de cachet effervescent.
Vous le mettez dans l'eau,
dans un contexte,
et d'un coup,
ça foisonne.
L'histoire des "sans dents" est
typique de cette espèce d'expansion
considérable du sens autour
de l'expression elle-même.
C'est-à-dire l'interprétation
politique des actions
jugées libérales par la gauche
à gauche de François Hollande
menées dans la conduite
des affaires.
Et cette interprétation-là vient
donner un sens aux "sans dents"
comme une sorte d'aveu
idéologique,
d'aveu
qu'il n'est plus de gauche.
-Si des leaders de gauche se mettent
à parler comme ça,
c'est peut-être pas par hasard.
C'est que depuis
des décennies,
la gauche française a, peu à peu,
perdu son électorat populaire
qui est parti vers d'autres horizons
et l'électorat de la gauche
est devenu un électorat
de couche moyenne,
de cols blancs et de bourgeois.
Mais il y a peut-être aussi
un embourgeoisement
de leur attitude,
une forme de mépris de classe
qui, paradoxalement,
s'exprime chez des gens
qui ne nous avaient pas
habitués à cela.
-L'expression
fait d'autant plus mal
que le François Hollande de 2012
a été élu
sur un programme très à gauche.
-Dans la campagne
de François Hollande,
il a fait le discours fondateur
le 22 janvier 2012 au Bourget.
Un candidat capable d'être président
a toujours un discours fondateur.
-Incarner le changement,
faire gagner la gauche.
-Alors, il sait, en effet,
que contre Nicolas Sarkozy,
qui est accusé à tort ou à raison
de néolibéralisme,
il y a un créneau, c'est le créneau,
en effet, traditionnel
de la gauche française
qui consiste à dire
qu'avec la gauche, on en finira
avec ce nouveau visage
capitaliste,
le capitalisme
financier, sans frontières,
apatride, créateur de crises.
-Dans cette bataille
qui s'engage,
je vais vous dire
qui est mon adversaire.
Mon véritable adversaire.
Il n'a pas de nom,
pas de visage,
pas de parti.
Il ne présentera jamais
sa candidature.
Il ne sera donc pas élu.
Et pourtant, il gouverne.
Cet adversaire,
c'est le monde de la finance.
L'audience applaudit.
...
-C'est ça qui a été retenu,
mais c'est une phrase susceptible
de lui être reprochée
parce que c'est jamais assez,
quand vous êtes dans l'opposition,
même interne au Parti Socialiste,
on s'en donne à coeur joie.
-On verra ce qui restera
quelques mois plus tard
de ce message :
"Mon ennemi, c'est la finance."
-Mais deux ans après son élection,
en 2014, ses sympathisants
déchantent. Moins d'un sur deux
lui fait confiance.
Musique enjouée
...
-Moi, c'est une année,
je fais campagne aux municipales,
donc je rencontre
des tas de personnes.
Et c'est une année où me revient,
non pas en boomerang,
mais, je dirais,
un manche de râteau,
ces expressions...
Pas de désespoir,
mais :
"Vous n'étiez pas au rendez-vous,
vous n'avez pas été au rendez-vous,
"on est déçus, on est mal,
"on attendait beaucoup en termes
de lutte contre les inégalités,
le fameux :
"Mon ennemi, c'est la finance."
On attendait beaucoup
en termes simplement de justice
et on a eu peu.
Malheureusement, François Hollande,
et peut-être Manuel Valls,
ne l'ont pas entendu.
-La famille socialiste
est déboussolée,
mais François Hollande, en 2014,
assume son virage politique.
*-Jusque-là,
il se disait socialiste,
hier,
il a franchi le pas.
-Suis-je un social-démocrate ?
Oui.
Au sens où ce pacte
de responsabilité,
qu'est-ce que c'est d'autre
qu'une démarche
de compromis social,
donc sociale-démocrate ?
-Ca a troublé
l'électorat socialiste,
c'est surtout l'électorat central,
qui est le plus important
qui se dégrade et puis,
ça s'accélèrera par la suite, quoi.
-A force de vouloir
ménager la chèvre et le chou,
à la fois le libéralisme
et la social-démocratie,
ils n'arrivent plus à rien,
sinon à mettre
quelques pansements
sur une jambe de bois.
Ils corrigent un système,
mais ils ne le font pas bouger.
Et nous,
un certain nombre,
avec Martine Aubry,
Jean-Marc Ayrault,
on ne réussit pas
à faire passer le message
que la tentation néo-libérale
n'est plus une vue de l'esprit
ou un écrit d'économistes atterrés,
mais une réalité.
-Après les révélations
sur les "sans dents",
la rupture
avec le peuple se creuse.
Près de 3/4 de l'électorat de gauche
ne veut plus de François Hollande.
*-L'affaire Thévenoud,
les "sans dents",
le virage social-libéral,
les raisons ne manquent pas.
-Une dégringolade qui va profiter
à l'un de ses jeunes
conseillers :
Emmanuel Macron.
Il ne manie pas l'humour
comme son mentor,
mais va aussi se laisser piéger
par ses petites phrases.
-Il y a, dans cette société,
une majorité de femmes.
Il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup, illettrées.
-Après le scandale
des "sans dents", voici maintenant
celui des "illettrées".
-Des petites phrases
lourdes de conséquences.
-Monsieur Emmanuel Macron,
ministre de l'Economie,
de l'Industrie
et du Numérique.
*-Il revient par la grande porte.
Lui qui avait quitté son poste
de secrétaire général adjoint
de l'Elysée début juillet
s'est assis,
pour la première fois ce matin,
à la table du Conseil des ministres.
-Fin août 2014,
le destin d'Emmanuel Macron
se joue peut-être sur une démission.
-Je dirais qu'il faut savoir
quitter la scène
quand on ne sait pas jouer
plus longtemps la comédie.
-A 36 ans,
le protégé de François Hollande
remplace le frondeur
et trop à gauche Arnaud Montebourg
au ministère de l'Economie.
Un profil plus jeune,
plus fidèle,
plus libéral, aussi.
-Il était le contraire
de Montebourg.
Franchement,
le grand contraire de Montebourg.
-Bonne chance, Manu.
Vive le redressement productif
de l'économie française.
Vive la République,
vive la France.
L'audience applaudit.
-Emmanuel Macron est l'homme qui,
depuis 2012, murmure
ses conseils à l'oreille
de François Hollande.
A Bercy, il a pour collègue
Marylise Lebranchu, élue bretonne
et socialiste pur jus.
-Emmanuel Macron,
il est aux manettes
quand il est secrétaire
général adjoint.
Quand il passe au gouvernement,
il passe d'un poste
de pouvoir silencieux
à un poste
de pouvoir effectif.
-Le choix
d'Emmanuel Macron est
forcément un tournant.
La perception
qu'ont les politiques
de l'entreprise
a profondément changé
dans le logiciel socialiste,
c'est très clair.
On revient à la réalité.
La création de richesses
se fait par les entreprises.
Pas par hasard.
-En passant de l'ombre
à la lumière,
Emmanuel Macron impose son style,
en décalage complet
avec celui de son mentor.
*-Sûr de lui à l'Elysée,
mais aussi, auparavant
à la banque Rothschild
où il a fait fortune.
Bardé de diplômes, Emmanuel Macron
n'a jamais caché son ambition.
-J'arrive
tout auréolé d'une réputation
qui m'est faite
par la presse,
je dois le dire.
Jugez-moi sur les actes
et sur les paroles.
-Le voeu d'Emmanuel Macron
va très vite
être exaucé,
car côté paroles,
il sort l'artillerie lourde.
Comme ministre,
puis comme candidat
et une fois élu
président de la République,
il va faire un usage massif
et délibéré de la petite phrase.
-La vie d'un entrepreneur
est souvent plus dure
que celle d'un salarié
parce qu'il peut tout perdre.
-Là où François Hollande
a toujours mesuré
ses propos en public, lui,
assume sa méthode : le parler-vrai.
-Il faut dire ce qui marche pas.
Je ne cèderai rien.
Bonjour !
-A coup de petites phrases,
il dresse le portrait
d'un pays de Gaulois réfractaires
où les jeunes devraient
vouloir devenir milliardaires
plutôt qu'être enclins
à la fainéantise.
-Ca va ?
*-Même franc-parler maladroit
et dévastateur,
devant ces militants CGT.
-Il y a toute une vérité
d'Emmanuel Macron
qui se dit
dans ces petites phrases.
-Je vais être honnête, je n'y crois
pas, c'est pour ça que je fais ça.
-Je ne pense pas
que ce soit voulu
qu'il sorte des trucs
comme ça.
Quoique.
-Avec sa méthode, Emmanuel Macron
dérange, bouscule, transgresse.
Il analyse les problèmes
avec froideur et ne voit pas l'effet
dévastateur que peut avoir
son parler-vrai.
Une déconnexion totale résumée
par l'affaire
des "illettrées".
Une petite phrase lâchée
à sa première interview
comme ministre
à propos de sa réforme
du permis de conduire.
-Le ministre évoque la nécessité
de petites réformes,
il se met alors à parler du prix
du permis de conduire
et prend l'exemple
des abattoirs bretons Gad. Ecoutez.
Le permis de conduire,
dans ce pays,
il coûte en moyenne 1500 euros.
Il faut attendre plusieurs mois
ou années
avant de pouvoir le passer.
Dans les sociétés qui sont dans
mes dossiers, il y a la société Gad.
Vous savez ?
Cet abattoir.
Il y a, dans cette société,
une majorité de femmes,
il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup, illettrées.
Pour beaucoup,
on leur explique :
"Vous n'avez plus d'avenir à Gad
ou aux alentours.
"Allez travailler à 50 ou 60 km."
Ces gens n'ont pas le permis.
On va leur dire quoi ?
Il faut payer 1500 euros ?
-"Illettrées",
la formule fait bondir
les salariées de la société Gad.
-Vous avez entendu le ministre ?
-Oui, qui ce matin a dit
que la plupart des femmes
de la société Gad étaient
des illettrées.
On vient vous prouver qu'on n'est
pas illettrées, qu'on a un permis,
qu'il y a des administratifs
et qu'on sait toutes lire et écrire.
-Tant d'études pour sortir ça,
j'aurais honte.
-Quand on connaît pas les choses,
on ferme sa gueule.
-Gad, l'histoire
d'une petite affaire familiale
passée de 20 salariés,
dans les années 50,
à plus de 2500,
dans les années 2000.
-Lorsque j'ai été élu
maire Lampaul,
j'avais plus de salariés
à Lampaul-Guimiliau
que d'habitants.
-Fragilisée par la concurrence
des pays de l'est,
l'entreprise bretonne
ne résiste pas
au changement d'époque.
Le couperet tombe
le 11 octobre 2013,
après une année
de conflit social incarné
par le délégué syndical
Olivier Le Bras
aux côtés du maire de Lampaul,
en larmes.
-La décision qui a été prise
par l'actionnaire
principal Cecab,
c'est-à-dire...
C'est-à-dire validation...
Laissez-moi parler.
Validation du plan de continuation,
et autorisation
des 883 licenciements.
La foule hue.
-C'était un village qui était
complètement par terre et c'était,
je dirais, toute une région
qui était très affectée
par ce qui venait de se passer.
-Ces salariés qui, soi-disant,
ne savent pas lire,
vont en tout cas se faire entendre.
-Moi, j'ai senti
comme un deuxième couperet.
Un autre coup de bâton
à un moment où on n'en avait pas
besoin. Il nous insulte.
-Des choses comme il a dit,
ça se dit pas.
Pour une personne si haut placée,
même une personne normale,
même un ouvrier,
il dira pas ça de gens
qui travaillent en usine.
-On nous parle comme si on était
des moins-que-rien.
-Ben, ça fait mal, quand même.
Ca fait mal.
On ne comprenait pas pourquoi
on était ciblés
alors qu'on était en difficulté.
-T'as pas su lire, t'as pas
su écrire et t'as pas le permis.
Regarde bien ça.
Donc,
c'est pas de ta faute,
ou peut-être, pour eux,
mais on te le montre bien,
comme si on montrait
un mauvais bulletin
à un élève devant tout le monde.
-Pour moi, c'est une grande erreur
de communication.
Il pouvait pas imaginer
ce qu'il allait faire,
c'est-à-dire faire mal
à des gens qui travaillaient là.
-Ca aurait été moins stigmatisant
pour nous
si derrière,
il apportait la solution.
"Nous, l'Etat, on va mettre
tant de millions
"sur les permis de conduire,
"on va aider les gens qui ont
des difficultés à lire et à écrire
"pour accéder à ce bien commun".
-Je conçois, il a voulu protéger
quelque chose
qu'il voulait mettre en place,
le permis à 1 euro,
à ce moment-là,
mais il n'avait pas à utiliser
ce mot-là. Pas ça.
-Il y a
dans cette société
une majorité de femmes.
Il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup, illettrées.
-Je suis d'ici,
les deux pieds dans cette terre
qui est très touchée
par la crise de l'agroalimentaire
et de Gad en particulier.
Le matin,
je... J'entends cette phrase,
comme un...
Un coup énorme,
et pour moi, un coup dans le dos.
La phrase,
elle est d'une violence inouïe.
-L'expression emballe
la classe politique.
-Il n'a sans doute
jamais rencontré
une ouvrière
de l'agroalimentaire.
Ce monsieur n'est pas venu
voir sur place.
Ce monsieur,
alors qu'il est là
pour aider les salariés,
les enfonce et les caricature.
-Quelle méconnaissance
de la réalité
de l'intelligence ouvrière
dans notre pays.
-Il arrive avec un franc-parler,
moi, je reçois
cinq sur cinq, parce que,
quand on regarde
la réalité de ce qu'il dit,
peut-être que c'est mal formulé,
mais voilà la réalité des choses.
On a des salariés qui font
une tâche depuis longtemps,
qui sont salariés depuis longtemps,
mais qui n'ont pas la capacité,
à l'heure actuelle,
s'ils ne sont pas formés,
à faire autre chose.
Ca peut être perçu comme
caricatural, et ça l'est en partie,
mais de dire :
"Il faut qu'on change les choses."
Je le perçois comme ça.
-Vous pouvez dire,
quand vous êtes politique,
"il y a trop d'illettrisme
en France",
ça existe, c'est vrai,
c'est une réalité,
faut la prendre en compte,
la dire, la décrire,
mais il faut la décrire
avec chaleur humaine.
Il faut la décrire en disant :
"Je sais qu'on ne vous a pas donné
cette chance-là."
"Moi, politique, je dois
vous donner cette chance-là."
C'est autre chose
que de balayer comme ça,
en disant :
"Il y a des illettrés,
ça pose problème."
-Erreur de jeunesse,
si je puis dire.
Un vieux de la vieille
n'aurait pas parlé comme ça.
Il aurait dit :
"Dans cette entreprise
que j'ai visitée,
"avec des personnes qui sont
attachées à leur travail,
"qui le font
avec professionnalisme,
"il y a un certain nombre
pour qui il faudrait
"une formation complémentaire
de ceci..."
Le mot "illettré",
ça donnait le sentiment
qu'il traitait une entreprise
d'illettrée.
Ca lui revient dans la gueule.
-Première petite phrase,
et première conséquence
pour le jeune ministre,
pour qui la journée s'annonce
difficile.
-J'appelle Emmanuel Macron,
et je lui expliquais
que seule l'excuse publique
pourra réparer
la déchirure que ces gens ont
forcément ressenti.
Il avait l'air surpris
par cette demande d'excuse.
-L'après-midi même,
il se retrouve
dans l'arène démocratique,
face à des députés
prêts à lui faire payer
son parler vrai.
-La parole est à madame
Laure de La Raudière
-Merci.
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
ce matin,
votre ministre de l'Economie
a traité les salariés
des entreprises Gad d'illettrés.
C'est inadmissible.
Quel mépris ! Après le scandale
des "sans dents",
voici maintenant
celui des illettrés.
Condamnerez-vous ces propos ?
-C'est sans pitié,
l'Assemblé nationale.
Il n'a jamais pénétré
dans l'hémicycle.
Il doit être surpris
que les députés en font une affaire.
C'est comme ça.
-Les salariés de Gad
et les Français
méritent votre respect, le respect
des membres du gouvernement.
-On ne se rend pas compte
à quel point c'est un moment fort,
et qu'il est compliqué
de parler à l'Assemblée,
avec l'émotion et avec le bruit.
Il sent qu'il faut tout de suite
qu'il apaise.
Il n'est pas venu
pour faire des combats
sur des petites phrases,
mais pour porter
une vraie transformation,
une amélioration
de la société française.
-La parole est
à monsieur Emmanuel Macron,
ministre de l'Economie,
de l'Industrie et du Numérique.
Mes chers collègues,
on écoute la réponse.
-Merci de m'offrir
l'occasion de répondre,
pour exprimer devant
la représentation nationale
deux regrets.
Le premier regret,
c'est pour les propos
que j'ai tenus ce matin,
si j'ai blessé et parce que
j'ai blessé des salariés.
C'est inacceptable et ça n'est pas
ce que je voulais faire.
Si vous écoutez
ce que j'ai pu dire ce matin,
si je prenais cet exemple
précisément,
c'est que ces salariés
n'ont pas eu la formation
qu'ils étaient en droit d'attendre.
Mon premier regret,
mes excuses les plus plates,
elles vont à l'égard des salariés
que j'ai pu blesser,
que j'ai blessés,
et je ne m'en excuserai
jamais assez.
-Merci, monsieur le ministre.
-Ses premières excuses,
Emmanuel Macron les fait à Paris,
sous les ordres de la République.
-Des choses ne marchent pas
qu'il faut dénoncer.
On le fait parfois maladroitement.
Je l'ai fait et je me suis excusé
auprès des gens que j'ai blessés.
Mais ce qui compte avant tout,
c'est de régler les problèmes.
-Il faudra attendre quatre mois
pour qu'il se décide
à aller en Bretagne affronter
les personnes qu'il a vexées.
-Il a attendu trop longtemps,
je pense que c'est ça qui...
C'est ça qui a été
le plus douloureux, quelque part.
-Il accepte une rencontre
avec une centaine
d'anciens salariés,
mais à huis clos.
-Il a été très clair.
Il a dit : "Je ne veux pas
de journaliste,
"je ne veux personne,
que moi."
-Sur le principe,
ça me dérangeait pas.
Ce qui m'importait, c'est
qu'il vienne les yeux dans les yeux
voir ces salariés,
qu'il s'excuse devant eux,
qu'il y ait un échange.
-L'ambiance était très tendue
et l'atmosphère plus que lourde.
-Il rentre dans la salle,
il traverse la foule.
A ce moment-là, c'est tendu.
Ca siffle, ça hue,
mais c'est respectueux,
pas d'insulte.
-Il a dit qu'il s'excusait.
"Je m'excuse pour les propos
que j'ai prononcés."
-La salle s'apaise, et ensuite,
il prend le temps
d'aller voir le maximum de gens
pour échanger avec eux.
Voilà comment ça s'est passé.
Les premières minutes
et les dernières
sont plus les mêmes, quoi.
-Une demie heure plus tard
et des excuses
droit dans les yeux,
Emmanuel Macron se voit remettre
un paquet de pâtes en alphabet,
un clin d'oeil
pour redescendre sur terre.
-C'est gentil de sa part !
Yvon est un brave mec.
-Monsieur le ministre,
qu'avez-vous appris
de cet échange ?
-Beaucoup de choses
que je garderai pour moi.
C'est la règle du jeu.
Quand je dis que c'est intime,
c'est intime.
C'était un bon moment,
j'ai vu de belles personnes.
J'ai vu de belles personnes,
c'était émouvant.
Ils sont fiers de ce qu'ils sont,
et je suis très fier d'eux.
-On a tous été,
dans cette salle,
à se dire : "Il a osé venir,
"et il est à l'écoute
de nos problèmes."
-J'ai entendu beaucoup dire
"c'était courageux".
Non, je regrette,
c'était normal.
Il a pu rencontrer des gens
sans avoir l'angle de la caméra
qui le favorise.
Et ça, je pense
qu'il a forcément été enrichi
par ce contact-là.
Et ça, c'est ce qu'il faut faire.
-Emmanuel Macron va au contact
et arrive à retourner
une salle hostile à son égard.
Cet épilogue dans le sourire
l'a-t-il
conforté dans son usage
du parler cash ?
Malgré ses excuses, il ne semble pas
avoir retenu la leçon.
Ceux qui pensaient qu'il changerait
de méthode en sont pour leur frais.
Il va récidiver, au point
de le soupçonner de provocation.
Comme lorsqu'il croise,
quelques années plus tard,
en tant que président
de la République,
un jeune sans emploi
lors des journées du patrimoine
à l'Elysée.
-Vous êtes à Pôle emploi ?
-J'envoie des CV,
ça fait rien.
-Dans l'hôtellerie
et la restauration,
dans le bâtiment,
il n'y a pas un endroit où je vais
où ils ne cherchent pas de gens.
L'hôtel-restaurant,
je traverse la rue,
je vous en trouve.
Il faut être prêt à travailler,
avec les contraintes du métier.
-Je pense
que beaucoup de Français
se disent que tout ça,
c'est calculé. Non.
Il y a des moments,
ça sort comme ça.
Il faut ensuite le gérer.
Ca fait partie du bloc
des expressions qui lui reviennent
dans la figure,
qui peuvent faire dire de lui
que c'est arrogant,
c'est méprisant, c'est hautain.
Ceux qui réussissent, bien,
les autres se démerdent.
-Je viens d'une culture,
je pense que c'est la même
qu'Emmanuel Macron,
le travail, on l'attend pas,
on va le chercher.
Et quelque part,
il le prend en main, il lui dit :
"Tu vas y arriver,
bats-toi, tu vas y arriver."
C'est perçu comme de l'arrogance
alors que cette phrase
est plutôt bienveillante
à l'égard de ce jeune.
-Pour les visiteurs qui n'auraient
pas réussi à le croiser,
reste sa photo sur papier glacé.
-Emmanuel Macron,
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas fait
d'élections locales.
On a tous connu ça,
quand on est élu local.
Vous devez apprendre
à leur parler,
à ces personnes.
Qu'aurait fait un Mitterrand ?
"Je vous comprends,
jeune homme."
Il a un conseiller.
"Prenez note.
"Ecrivez-moi. Je vous aiderai.
"Parce qu'il y a du travail."
-C'est difficile pour celui
qui est en difficulté
d'entendre
"bats-toi plus",
mais au fond, qu'est-ce qu'on attend
d'un chef d'Etat ?
Qu'il nous emmène
vers quelque chose de meilleur.
-Sa radicalité,
Emmanuel Macron l'assume
et va jusqu'à la mettre en scène,
comme dans cette vidéo,
filmée et mise en ligne
par l'Elysée.
-La politique sociale, regardez !
On met un pognon de dingue
dans les minima sociaux
et les gens sont pauvres.
Les gens qui naissent pauvres
restent pauvres.
Ceux qui tombent pauvres
On doit permettre aux gens
de s'en sortir.
-Il reste quelqu'un
qui pense qu'il a raison,
le matin, le midi, le soir,
et qu'ayant raison,
il peut se permettre
beaucoup de choses.
-Qui n'utilise pas cette expression,
le "pognon",
"on dépense un pognon de dingue" ?
Je pense qu'un président doit parler
comme il est,
donc utiliser
des expressions familières,
ça me choque pas.
-Emmanuel Macron est un enfant
du parler cash.
Il considère non pas
que c'est un moins, mais un plus.
Et puis, il y a
une philosophie macronienne,
les premiers de cordée :
on considère que l'action politique
est faite avant tout
pour les premiers de cordées,
qui vont montrer la voie à ceux
qui sont derrière.
C'est une conception
extrêmement élitiste de la société.
-Sa vision du monde
et la société à laquelle il aspire,
Emmanuel Macron en donne
un aperçu très clair
ce jour de juillet 2017,
devant des créateurs de start-up,
réunis à Paris.
Après "les illettrés",
"les gens qui ne sont rien".
-Une gare,
c'est un lieu où on croise
les gens qui réussissent
et les gens qui ne sont rien,
parce que c'est un lieu où on passe.
-Comment peut-on dire ça,
"des gens qui ne sont rien" ?
-Alors là, c'est très fort.
-Vous vous rendez compte ?
C'est d'un mépris...
En effet, là,
extrêmement impressionnant.
-C'est une phrase
que vous pouvez pas avaler,
qui vous étouffe,
qui vous coupe le souffle.
-Ce qui me frappe là-dedans,
c'est qu'il a une opposition
entre le faire et l'être.
Ceux qui réussissent,
ce sont ceux qui sont
dans la transformation,
dans la création,
et ceux qui ne sont rien,
c'est des gens qui sont
dans la permanence de leur état,
inchangeables.
-Ce qui vous rassemble,
ce qui nous rassemble aujourd'hui,
c'est cet esprit...
...entrepreneurial.
-Les accidents de langage
de ce type,
qui sont proches du lapsus,
ils ont comme propriété
d'être toujours
sur le même registre.
Donc, ça révèle
avec d'autant plus de force
l'espèce de cohérence intérieure
d'un imaginaire social.
C'est quelque chose qui renvoie
à une idéologie politique,
presque de la défense de l'inégalité
comme une donnée naturelle.
-Emmanuel Macron,
c'est l'archétype
d'une tête bien formée
dans le moule de l'élite française.
Un parcours de gagnant,
conscient de sa position.
-C'est un enfant issu
d'une bourgeoisie médicale, aisée,
qui a fait les meilleures écoles,
qui est passé par l'ENA,
les grands corps,
vous voyez ?
L'inspection des finances...
On est dans une forme
de noblesse d'Etat.
-Il faut faire attention.
Ca peut abîmer. Ca peut abîmer.
On a besoin des bons élèves,
mais aussi de savoir pourquoi
d'autres ne peuvent pas réussir.
On peut être brillant,
on peut être cultivé,
et ne pas avoir
de pâte humaine suffisante
pour sentir que l'autre
peut être dévalorisé,
peut être humilié.
-Dans ces milieux,
il peut y avoir un mépris,
et s'il n'y a pas de mépris,
une distance sociale abyssale,
avec les gens dont on parle.
-Entre ces deux mondes,
celui de la haute sphère de l'élite
de Macron et celui du peuple,
l'incompréhension mutuelle grandit,
nourrie par des phrases
et des écarts de langage.
-Ca stigmatise, et les gens
n'aiment pas être stigmatisés,
n'aiment pas être montrés du doigt.
Au nom de quoi, le président,
quel que soit l'honneur
de sa fonction,
aurait-il le droit
de parler sur ce ton
de nous ?
Un président de la République,
ou un candidat à la présidence,
qui a une vocation à unir,
il faut qu'il positive ceux en bas,
qui ont une image d'eux
très négative,
qui sont
dans une situation de défiance.
Il faut qu'il les soulève,
il faut pas espérer
de manière naïve et technocratique
que c'est le haut
qui emportera le bas.
Ca se passe pas comme ça.
-La parole publique suppose
de la retenue, du choix des mots.
En effet, les mots sont...
Ils peuvent être blessants.
Un mot est une arme,
quelque part.
Pas forcément une arme létale,
mais une arme politique.
-Toutes ces petites phrases
démontrent
que ce qu'il avait dit
avec beaucoup de maladresse
- c'est en tout cas
ce que je pensais au début -
montre quand même
un peu de dédain
par rapport
à une certaine population.
-Attention à ce nouveau langage.
Ca vous permet d'exister
dans un premier temps,
et puis ça vous plombe.
Depuis qu'il est au pouvoir,
ça l'a pas servi, ça l'a plombé.
On met un pognon de dingue
dans des minima sociaux.
Il y en a qui sont,
pour beaucoup, illettrés.
-Il y a certainement
cette volonté de parler cash
qui vous fait dire
d'énormes bêtises.
Des mots...
C'est mieux dit que Sarkozy,
mais c'est
d'une violence effrayante.
Ca va créer des réflexes
extrêmement violents.
Les gilets jaunes,
ils se sont nourris
de ces petites phrases.
-Ca fait partie
de ces petits épisodes
qui alimentent la colère,
et malheureusement aussi,
parfois, la haine.
Ils klaxonnent.
...
-DANS TON CUL LA QUENELLE
-Avec le mouvement
des gilets jaunes, fin 2018,
Emmanuel Macron a connu,
comme président,
l'un des plus violents mouvements
de contestation du pouvoir.
-Dans les manifestations,
on a bien vu
les pancartes, les inscriptions
sur les gilets, etc.,
jusqu'à, d'ailleurs,
certains gilets jaunes
ont franchi une ligne
qui n'était pas acceptable,
c'est d'attiser la haine
à son égard.
Dans certaines manifestations,
on pendait Macron.
Là, c'est trop.
-A Angoulême,
le quotidien régional rapporte
ce simulacre d'exécution
d'Emmanuel Macron.
-Cette haine reprenait
à la fois les mots,
le langage,
et puis le parcours
d'Emmanuel Macron : Rothschild,
l'ENA, voire sa jeunesse, etc.
-Il y a une perception
qu'une élite gagne
de plus en plus d'argent
et s'en sort de mieux en mieux,
et une autre qui travaille dur,
mais qui n'y arrive pas.
Ensuite, il y a une étincelle,
l'augmentation des taxes
sur l'essence,
qui crée ce ras-le-bol.
Peut-être qu'à ce moment-là,
Emmanuel Macron incarne
ceux qui réussissent,
finalement,
et qu'il peut avoir donné
le sentiment de ne pas incarner
ceux qui galèrent,
qui travaillent.
-Quand vous n'avez plus rien
à perdre,
ce genre de phrases,
ça sert pas à apaiser.
Ca alimente un peu
ce feu de la haine,
ce feu de la colère.
Moi, je l'ai vu dans les yeux
des salariés, ce feu,
des gens qui étaient
pacifiques, doux,
mais qui n'avaient plus rien
à perdre,
parce qu'on leur enlevait tout.
Quand en plus,
au plus haut sommet de l'Etat,
les gens qui ont le pouvoir,
contrairement à ce qu'on dit,
on se permet de sortir
ce genre de phrases !
C'est violent,
c'est extrêmement violent.
-Emmanuel Macron a-t-il aujourd'hui
perçu les limites
de son franc-parler ?
-Il y a des phrases que je regrette,
des phrases qui ont été sorties
de leur contexte.
C'est une réalité.
Elles se sont agrégées.
Mais...
Je crois que j'ai compris
beaucoup de choses,
de la vie du pays,
de ce que...
Des impatiences
qu'on exprime avec sincérité,
- croit-on -
peuvent être mal comprises.
Même si on ressent
que c'est une injustice,
qu'on s'est mal compris,
c'est une erreur.
-Pour les anciens Gad,
le temps a passé,
mais l'étiquette reste.
-"Illetrés-Gad", quoi.
C'est lié, maintenant.
-Quand on me dit
"c'est vrai,
"t'es une illettrée, toi",
je souris,
mais ça fait un peu mal quand même.
-Joelle Crenn a ouvert
son restaurant
et emploie aujourd'hui
trois personnes.
-Ca va, monsieur ?
Très bien.
-Allez-y, monsieur.
-Olivier Le Bras est
agent de sécurité
à l'aéroport de Brest,
et siège
au conseil régional de Bretagne.
Depuis l'épisode
des "illettrés",
il veut porter
la parole ouvrière à l'Assemblée.
L'ancien ministre est devenu
président de la République.
Depuis le mouvement
des gilets jaunes
et son pic d'impopularité,
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas changé
sa méthode.
Peut-être a-t-il
déjà les yeux tournés
vers la prochaine
élection présidentielle,
tout comme François Hollande,
jamais loin des médias.
Tous deux ont payé cher
leurs petites phrases,
et espèrent peut-être renouer
avec le peuple.
Il leur faudra apprendre
à tenir leur langue.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...